let's start that again and we'll for
those of you watching live pardon the
interruption and for those of you that
are watching on youtube after during the
recording we had a little kerfuffle and
it is now fixed so anyway thanks for
joining Android design in action once
again I'm your host Roman Nurik joining
from Chelsea Market are a wonderful new
little recording studio here in New York
City and I'm joined today by Nick
butcher
hello hailing all the way from London
and today we're gonna talk about
football apps and uh you know the Super
Bowl just happens to everybody probably
thinking oh merican football apps now
we're gonna be talking about the other
kind of football soccer or European
football if you're you know if you call
it something else so right well the
Australians apparently call it something
else right well they call it soccer as
well I don't know
nevermind let's so we're gonna talk
about football tracking apps but we're
really going to talk about one app we're
gonna look at an app called live score
addict's maybe just interject a little
bit it may change from a regular format
where you normally kind of work with the
app clinic so the app clinic will take a
look at a bunch of applications within a
given topic and then we'll turn our
attention to one and and try and you
know we envisage how it might look with
the application of the Android design
principles we're mixing up a little bit
here and we were actually gonna go first
with we're looking at one application
which has come up from the suggested
topic from the app clinic and then those
guys are going to take it from us and
kind of run with some of our suggestions
and go a little bit deeper into some of
the implementation steps for the more
developer crowd out there absolutely a
good cash Nick so it is kind of a new
format if you're looking to nominate
your app to be reviewed at some point on
the App clinic and Android design in
action please still keep using the
Trello board for now we're going to keep
sourcing stuff from there and also if it
is a self-nomination if you're
nominating your own app please make sure
to state that because we want to make
sure that folks that are nominating
their own app get get precedence so with
that we're also going to talk about a
launcher icon specifically you have the
icons that
that appear you know that represent your
application in both the the Playstore on
the Google on the Google Play client as
well as on the web as well as on a
device once you install it so with that
let's let's get started so like I said
we're going to talk about one of this
tablet keeps shutting off so like I said
we're gonna talk about football apps and
specifically live score addicts
so let's get started Nick do you want to
introduce live score addicts sure so for
anyone who is a football or soccer fan
and this is this is one of those
applications which lets you keep on top
of fixtures and results essentially it's
quite a focused application it doesn't
do the whole gamut of kind of like news
and everything around that is very much
about kind of keeping track of what's
just happened or what's coming up and as
well as having quite a strong kind of
and during the game focus as well so you
might want to kind of have this
application open and be receiving
notifications and see what's going on
with other teams playing at the same
time so it's worth noting I believe
developers have just put out a redesign
and I hear it's a great improvement on
and on the on the previous look and feel
of the application and I think they've
done a pretty decent job but we've kind
of deep done little deep dive on some of
the kind of fit and finish and polish
aspects of the application to really
make it shine we do yeah and just to
reiterate you know anytime we look at an
app and we provide redesigns it's really
not we're not saying that the the app is
currently designed poorly or anything
like that we're just exploring other
ways in which to present that kind of
that information we do sometimes look at
apps that you know are are worse I guess
generally worse from an aesthetic and in
a you know UI standpoint but we
definitely don't don't mean to say you
know your app sucks here's a better
version it's purely just you know here's
some thoughts in which that you can use
to improve the app so with that so this
screen this is the first screen we're
going to take a look at we're take a
look at about three or four screens this
is basically the onboarding process and
it's kind of a wizard where you know it
takes you through the different
different leagues and lets you kind of
customize what are the things you want
to see in the app what are you
interested in I mean I'm guessing as if
you're a football fan you're not
than every single league out there
because there are millions you know even
just within the UK there you know
probably hundreds or thousands or
something so you can really customize
what specifically you're interested in
and then in the later steps you actually
gets a customized notifications which
things you want to be notified of you
know in the notification in the status
bar so we took a look at this screen and
you know we thought how can we make it
feel a little more Android II and so we
came up with a version that's using a
more common wizard like UI and this is
actually I posted some sample code for
this a few months ago is called wizard
pager so this is using some hints from
that wizard pager including things like
having a bottom bar for next in previous
it's worth noting here that you know
some folks think oh there's there's
already a back button on the device why
wouldn't you just use that
well actually had a talk with our design
team our Android user experience team
and they felt that in this case this is
actually one of those really weird edge
cases where you don't actually want to
overload the back button to go back in
the wizard since you have a very very
apparent on-screen next affordance so so
previous and next and at the bottom very
similar to like an okay cancel
presentation in dialogues and then for
indicating which step you're looking at
there's this little kind of strip at the
top that indicates your past step one
and now you're looking at step two and
step two is highlighted in green which
is your current step additionally we we
kind of bumped up the size of the
imagery and again in general we love to
to make images larger or image content
larger because it's a little more you
know engaging and so we made you know
the the country logo a little larger we
made the text a little larger and then
we also use more holo style elements for
the check boxes and things like that so
some very basic stuff but overall we
kind of tweaked the screen to to more
prominently highlight the content we
actually haven't we had added an action
bar at the top that's using a different
palette an inverted palette so that it
kind of fades away and feels more like
the the part of the system chrome the
system UI
rather than part of the application in
this case in a couple of things like
that
before we move on nicht is there
anything you wanted to add to our
wizards or just think what it might seem
like there's very small changes in the
screen for me it really works because
the use of more standard controls is
really kind of makes it a lot easier to
appreciate what's going on on this page
and that's very important when you're
talking about the very first thing the
users going to see when they first run
this application you've got this small
window of time to convince the user that
your application is easy to use and they
want to keep it and it's gonna be useful
so I think little bits like that you
know using the standard down controls
and making it immediately obvious and
easy to kind of like to pass the screen
is where and understand what it's
offering you it really really helped
here I mean better and better than this
might all even be to off you know some
kind of sensible defaults you might auto
detect which country they're in and home
them into some sensible defaults and
then allow the user to kind of go
through this customization flow at a
later point because it's it really is
this very very crucial time the first
time I used to runs an app so yeah the
visual changes here for me we're really
great I mean the bar at the top on the
original showing which step you're
currently on it didn't really speak to
me it's quite low contrast showing the
current step and there's repeated icons
right list there's the what little white
sliver and it's white on like a tan
background for the contrast is very poor
there yeah I'm having to move your thumb
like all the way to top corner to hit
next and so on and though I think that
you know the small changes that we may
really really make this screen much
easier to kind of understand and use
okay and one other thing I wanted to
mention is in general we actually have a
very good document in a design guide
that talks about health and as well as
like tutorials so in general the
guidance there is actually if you don't
if the user doesn't need to make a
decision immediately if you can just
stick with a default and that's okay for
like 60 70 % of people let them skip the
tutorial you don't want to force them to
go through something in this case you
know you could argue that the user has
to choose you know what they're
interested in because otherwise you know
you won't be able to present them any
sort of useful data but as soon as
you're done as soon as you know you're
done specifying the one thing you're
interested in let the users skip so find
some way to provide like a skip or just
started now function so let's let's move
on to the next screen which we looked at
which was the list of matches and so on
the on the left here you see the list of
matches and you'll notice that you know
this there's actually a number of
different ways you can sort this you can
sort this by the league you can sort
this by time a number of different
things
there's also we'll show this in the next
screen but there's also the navigation
drawer on the left
and we'll talk about that in a bit there
is also this button here that filters by
only live now matches so only matches
that are currently live and then you can
swipe left and right between yesterday
and tomorrow as well as today the issue
I found with this was that there's not
actually a yesterday - one in the
yesterday - two and so on you can only
see those three dates and it may be
because of some sort of you know policy
thing or maybe they don't have the data
but in that case you know do you really
need a scrollable a set of scrollable
tabs so what we decided to do here was
we kind of reimagined what it would look
like with just tabs and in a slightly
different color scheme we actually
tweaked the color scheme from like a a
very like a deep orangey brown to a
slightly more subdued brown and then we
used a kind of like a turf I call it a
turf green as the highlight as the
single accent that's used throughout so
this kind of this a dark ish desaturated
brown combined with the green kind of
gives it a more earthy a little more you
know simpler feel I'd say and then we
also you know switched over to the fixed
tabs to show yesterday today and
tomorrow and again you should still be
able to swipe between the three we also
removed the navigation drawer and switch
to an action bar spinner and I'll talk
about that on the next the next slide
and then we used a slightly different
presentation for the actual content the
actual matches themselves we made we
slightly made the live matches a little
more prominent in that left column here
you'll see that live matches are kind of
highlighted in green and then anytime
you have set up notifications for
individual
if you decided that you know I really
want to follow what happens in this
match you should you see a little kind
of green tick at the very top right and
it's not interactive it's probably worth
mentioning that if you wanted to make
this interactive have like a
notification button right in line with
the list item this should look very
different but this very is a very clear
signal that it's not interactive it's
purely an indicator we also bumped up
the again we bumped up the country flags
a little bit just to to make that pop a
little more since that's probably
something that's gonna get your
attention fairly quickly and we used
Roboto thin actually Roboto light here
as well as Roboto bold condensed to show
the actual current scores so now there
was a those whammy is there anything
else you wanted to mention Nick on the
screen just I'm it's got some room to
breathe now I think that the last screen
there before version as it were and
tried to stuff a lot of content into the
screen and in doing so made it less
possible like you I find it quite hard
to kind of like find the individual
event I'm looking for so in the
reimagining I really like the way that
you use them space and color and
contrast to you and to really kind of
give a hierarchy to the information so
it's really easy to find you know the
section you're looking for than the game
you're looking for or things like that
are important like a goal that's just
scored or game is on now really jump out
so I think the information hierarchy is
really what's things here for me I think
one of the biggest contrasts here is the
information density you'll see on the
left and in the current screen the
information density is very high so
there's you can see a lot of matches all
at once but I mean my guess is in
general if you're you know if you're a
fan following you know just a few games
that are happening now you probably
don't really care about all that
information you probably do care about
you know the two or three current games
as well as maybe you know a specific
league that has games today
so it's don't don't be afraid of letting
your content breathe by you know
increasing margins increasing spacing
and lowering slightly lowering
information density it'll make things a
little more readable as well as you know
make your concert a little more
consumable and just overall kind of
improve the aesthetic in general so
let's move on to the next screen which I
wanted to talk about and this is the
navigation jar versus the action bar
spinner so the action the navigation
drawer here provides you access to
things like matches competitions and
teams which are kind of like the top
three there are the three top level
structural elements as well as settings
and more and this is this is something
that we should we pointed out on the
last in the last episode in the Hangout
things like settings or help or about or
even just more stuff they generally
don't belong you know immediately
on-screen or hmm
in the primary navigation area and we
we've specifically kind of outlined that
things like settings help about Terms of
Service privacy policy those should
really belong in the action bar overflow
so when you press this action bar
overflow here in the action bar you
should see things like settings and help
and about so we would probably move
things like that to there so if you
remove settings and more you're just
left with three items and with you know
only three items to choose from three
navigational components the the
navigation drawer becomes a little bear
and so what you could do instead is you
could either use tabs or an action bar
spinner now in this case we were already
using tabs to switch between yesterday
today and tomorrow and so we decided to
switch to the action bar spinner is the
top-level core kind of structural
navigational component and so there you
can switch between matches competitive
competitions and teams and it very
clearly it makes clear the three main
sections of the app so let's move on to
the next component or the next screen
that we've looked at which was the match
detail screen and in the match details
screen we looked at a couple things
specifically we looked at the statistics
tab we also looked at just the
presentation of the current game state
so on the left you'll notice that you
know you have this the position title
strip or the scrollable tabs at the top
and then the content at the bottom and
then somewhere in the middle is actually
a fixed pane or a fixed
I guess a fixed UI element that
indicates the current state of the game
and so as you're swiping left and right
on the content or on the top of
scrollable tabs the middle part stays
fixed by the top and bottom actually
slide together and so it kind of loses
that feeling of of connectivity that in
or like almost like this tactile feeling
that you're actually moving a single
surface and so what we decided to do is
actually flip the two and we move the
the scrollable tabs below the data fixed
pain at the top we also tweaked the
presentation to to again kind of fall in
with our with our color scheme of that
brown and green and we also used basic
text contrast like like dark on on
accent or white on accent to again show
or guess more prominently show the
visual hierarchy of the information you
know the most important thing on the
screen right now is the current score to
the one as well as you know alternate or
alter your elements such as the the
names of the teams as well as the the
current time and then we we took a look
at statistics how can we make statistics
look better in general not much to say
here we just again use the same color
scheme we simplified everything into a
single row of information you notice
that on the left you have a row
indicating the details and then a row
for the progress bar we sent or not only
the progress bar I guess the the stats
bar we simply integrated the two into a
single row so that it's much easier to
scan alright so that was I was a doozy
Nick anything you want to add here
pretty nicely like yeah I think the
presentation really works much better
it's a lot more plausible you can just
kind of have a glance and see which way
the game is going by the stats and as
well yeah I completely agree about
connecting that page a title strip to
the actual view pager it felt quite
disconnected before before version when
you're moving the body of the content
and there's a stationary pair between
you and the tab strip moving it felt
very disconnected so that's good change
there another thing I'll mention is that
in the previous sorry in the previous or
in the current details for the game
what it was the current game state
you'll see that there's a little
notification icon it's not interactive
and it's so it's not really useful it's
just an indicator saying that yes you
have notifications turn on for this game
or not so we actually made that an
action bar icon so that when you touch
that it toggles the state of whether or
not you want notifications for the game
all right so let's let's move to the
next screen which is the tablet mark up
and Nikki want to talk about this one
yeah so here we've refocused on the
in-game experience we figured that
tablet is mostly going to be used can I
guess at at home you were watching the
game already and you're kind of wanting
to kind of have a second screen
experience so what we try to do here is
float up all the different sections that
on the phone version the owner and the
kind of view pager type set up onto a
single kind of hire a single dashboard
so as Roman pointed out the most
important thing on the screen and is you
know the current school what's going on
so we've made that kind of very very big
emboldened very clear exactly what's
going on you can't really miss you know
the current score on this screen here
and the rest of the information we kind
of have this kind of the horizontal ease
scrollable so you can actually flick
around and see what's going on are the
you know some videos being posted how is
the live table change or quite finish
and the line up here but you can you
know click in to see some of the line up
who's playing in the roster so we've
really tried to use the extra real
estate to kind of make information
easier to get out and it kind of a bit
more playful and visual and then the
phone kind of view page is set up but
while retaining the most important
information on the screen the whole time
yeah and I think that you know the
addition of the logos for the teams is
also another way to to use visual
elements to better kind of hint at
what's going on
so you could do even more here you could
do like things like you could have the
the background use the or or take the
team logos and use them in the
background look up in a blurry state you
can really make this like really
immersive and I think this is a great
start this is a great way to to start
showing all the different pieces almost
like at it like a game dashboard all at
once on a tablet when you have a larger
screen
yeah all right so let's in the interest
of time let's move on to rich
notification and this is something that
Chris Bane's put together and
unfortunately wasn't able to join which
kind of sucks he should definitely join
next time but this is an example
expanded notification for you know let's
say you turn on notifications for a
specific game and something happens and
let's say you then expand it so here's
you know what it can look like and this
is using the custom layout again you
have different options for notifications
you can just show a photo or more text
you can also provide a custom layout
entirely and so this is an example of
what that can look like you still use
the app icon to some degree to indicate
that you're you know looking at the live
score addicts app and so that's what
that little soccer ball icon means but
you also show you know the most
information most important information
first which is you know the current
score as well as what was the latest
score so you know the 20th minute in the
20th minute I'm gonna butcher his name
is it popescu or perpetuo
okay in the 20th minute this guy scored
a goal which is you know which is great
information to see as soon as you you
know expand the notification yeah this
is a great start I think there's there's
a little potential for the richer
notifications and things like sports
updates like you wanna have the
information kind of quickly but if you
can have you know that much richer
visual way of delivering it I think
users gonna be delighted by that I think
that's something they're gonna see and
really really kind of like and jump on
about your application so I think
there's a little stuff you could do here
and we're playing around with some ideas
and we talked about maybe having you
know a freeze-frame of the goal or a
celebration as you know the pitcher
payload and permission notification
there's a lot of things that you could
do with an application here which I'm
quite excited about yeah absolutely
anytime you can use photos anything you
have access to photo content you know
showing it there or even a thumbnail
still from a video is really useful and
if you show a video you can even do
something like overlay a fake you know
play icon to indicate that this is a
video so definitely use all the content
that you have to your advantage and rich
notifications it's really easy all you
need to do is you use notification
compat provide some intents and you're
set so there's no reason not to do it
let's move on in the interest of time so
that was it for football absent lights
radek's let's jump in to launch our
icons and I think we're running a little
low on time since we had that little
kerfuffle in the beginning we'll try to
zoom through this so Launcher icons
basically you know the Android design
guide has a little bit about icons in
general so an icon is a graphic that
takes up a small portion of screen real
estate provides a quick intuitive
representation of an action of status or
your app so really in the space of you
know 48 by 48 dips you have to make the
best use of that space to represent what
your app does what it means whether
that's an icon representing your brand
if you have an existing service or if
it's you know if it's a utility app in
that space try as best as possible to
represent what the user will benefit
from once they use your app so one
example is there's a little side project
that I worked on that was just basically
a single text box notepad and the icon
was literally just a text box it was it
showed a little cursor and you know it
showed the text box so you can do things
like that you don't necessarily have to
use this this selected e synecdoche - to
take like this very abstract idea and
and compress it down into a single
little object but certainly that's one
possible way so let's look at some
guidelines on Launcher icons again the
the size the actual asset size is 48 by
48 dips in xhdpi that's 96 by 96 for
tablets for Nexus 10 specifically you
should provide an xxhdpi icon and that's
144 by 144 pixels also when you upload
your when you upload your app to Google
Play the it requests a large app icon so
they can show it and all its beautiful
glory on tablets and phones and so on
and that should be 512 by 512 pixels and
generally you know what we found is you
can probably start by you know designing
a 512 by 512 maybe actually use 576 by
576 for some reason now you can start
with that and then slowly scale down
it's generally a good idea to start
large and scale down rather than vice
versa and then in terms of padding this
is something that that's definitely
changed over the years for Android we
used to request a fairly large padding
region but these days you should really
just
use either the full image size meaning
no padding or if you have a very very
square icon then try to use about three
dips of pad and give or take it's really
up to you but in general you know try to
make it fit in nicely with the rest of
the system icons as well as third-party
icons and those are generally going to
take up the full image size or have
about one to three dips of padding
before we move on and fly through this
make any any other comments on launchers
now you're nailing it all right let's do
it
so a couple more guidelines try to use a
distinct silhouette so don't just you
know stick some some graphic inside of a
square or a circle that can work for for
now at work as a default but try to
really use a distinct silhouette and
we'll show good examples of that in a
bit also you know keep it simple at the
top make sure that your icon you know
when it's good when it's scaled down it
still means something it still makes
sense but at the very micro level feel
free to add details like noise or subtle
drop shadows or and things like that as
you see fit and then very important
don't try to mimic other platforms so
you know if you have an existing app on
Windows Phone or or an iPhone iOS
don't just simply copy over your icon
it's okay to copy over the general idea
for the icon but make sure that it fits
well with the rest of the system and
fits in with the guidelines so let's
look at actually before we look at some
examples we recently made changes to the
guidelines in the sense that it used to
be just you know facing forward you
should make your icon facing forward but
now there's a slight 3d perspective and
you'll see some examples here there's
you know just a few dips of perspective
that you see at the very top and here's
the rough kind of camera angle that you
could use to achieve that we don't have
any numbers or dimensions or anything
but somebody asked for the numbers this
is the best we could do for now but
here's roughly what it should look like
if you're doing this in a 3d editing a
piece of 3d editing software here's some
not good examples yet we're not there
yet some tools that can help you with
icon generation there's the Android
asset studio which I'm sure many of you
familiar with you can actually just
generate icons for you just to start
with
you should probably when you're ready to
ship your product definitely use
you know hire a designer and have them
do like a custom icon for you that's
that's really that has a distinct
silhouette that is very very unique to
your app it's gonna really make it pop
when users are scanning Google Play as
well as the boilerplate boilerplate that
are provided for free by Android icons
com so they also give you circle and
square icons but using those basic
shapes you can you know change it to
whatever whatever silhouette you need
the good thing about these is that it
actually has that correct perspective
and correct styling actually correct
example styling that you can use as well
as different sizes they actually provide
to 512 by 512 as well as the you know
all the different smaller sizes that are
shown on the device and finally here
we're at a few examples of icons that
follow our guidelines so Falcon Pro is
an example and they show a slight
perspective above the kind of futuristic
bird-like creature page once users kind
of a circle a very basic circle but it's
really just that's their app icon it's
their branding is very circular pocket
which does something interesting with
the perspective they actually show their
brand colors in the depth of that Square
Expedia which is one of my favorites and
this is you know again a very distinct
silhouette it's a briefcase effectively
but it shows their branding really well
and that briefcase again is is tilted at
just the right perspective we also have
some good examples from from Google i/o
app which which we've open-sourced as
well as solid Explorer which is a file
explorer app and again it's a folder
that's slightly open and has that very
slight perspective at the top alright so
I think that was it for Launcher icons
and if you all have a channel I know I
think this is one of the most important
assets that you can put in your entire
application like users will judge your
application
you know quite unique when you're
scanning a list of applications in the
based or on your icon almost alone so if
you you know do definitely work with a
designer and make sure they understand
these guidelines that we put out because
this is such an important asset yeah we
probably shouldn't mention at the very
beginning but if you have if so if you
have to hire a designer just to do your
icon and a lot of designers are actually
just icon designers they don't do UI and
things
like that it's definitely worth the the
investment this is something that you
know users will see immediately if it
stands out in the store listing in the
list of apps that they you know in their
search results if it stands out then
that's gonna be well worth the
conversions that you get so moving on to
design news and again we're way over
time but I think this is actually pretty
good for a scheduling kerfuffle not a
scheduling problem but the kerfuffle
that happened with our technology in the
beginning so for design news we have
only a few things
so speaking of Launcher icons Michael
cook has actually provided some PS DS of
a couple example icons and it's very
similar to the boiler plates and
essentially you can you know drop in
your stuff and and tweak it in Photoshop
as you see fit
and that's the link there you can
download it and it's I'm guessing it's
free of charge and all that next we have
yes thank you Michael next actually I
wanted to highlight one of the designs
from the Google+ community the Android
design community so rajesh honda sorry
if i mispronounce your name but rajesh
actually has been posting a whole bunch
of different examples design concepts to
the google+ community and i think some
of them are really wonderful this
specific one has a really unique color
palette and it's I think it's just
really well done the you know the
information that you're currently
looking at the most important
information the the unit conversion
right converting between kilometers and
meters for example that pops immediately
nothing else has as much contrast as
that I think that that's just like one
of the one of the better designs we've
seen from the community and also you
could there's a little drag candles on
the lefts that you could switch between
converting from kilometers to meters
right usually all right and the last I
think the last piece of design news is
so we talked a lot about apps on the
show but we don't really talk about
games and that's because mostly you know
usually games have their own very very
custom bespoke UI and this is an example
of a puzzle game that uses lots and lots
of holo elements and even uses the holo
color palette in a really successful way
so I just wanted to point out that you
know if you're building a game
especially
a puzzle game or like a brainteaser
things like that you don't have to have
your own custom UI you can definitely
succeed it still with holo
so just wanted to point that out and put
it out there for y'all to check out
anything else that we missed Nick before
we sign off no no I think that's towed
it alright okay so thanks again for
joining
as always I'm Roman Nurik and bye from
me Nick butcher and we will see you
hopefully next week where Adam will join
us once again Adam actually couldn't
make it today because of some you know
some stuff at home oh wait he's on
vacation that's right but yes I
hopefully will join you next week as
always see you next time
and remember to tune into the and the
after Nick this Friday as well to see
what those guys do to some of these
football score wraps as well that's
right that's right
All Right see y'all thanks for joining